jQuery is an extremely popular JavaScript library meant to make a number of
common JavaScript tasks simpler, via a consistent API across all browsers.
In other words, jQuery makes your life easier.
As of 2014, almost 62% of the top 100,000 websites all use jQuery,
which is pretty incredible.
Performing AJAX requests that work properly in every browser is,
well it's a big pain in the butt.
Luckily we can use jQuery's AJAX methods and
leave some of the drudgery of supporting old browsers to jQuery.
It's important to know that it's extremely common for
developers to use libraries to write AJAX calls.
There's no problem with using libraries to simplify the code you have to write,
especially with something like AJAX.
In order to use jQuery we need to use jQuery objects, and
to do that we'll be using syntax like you see here within script.js.
We're creating a few variables over here each of
which has a dollar sign in front of em.
Now this dollar sign doesn't mean anything, it's just a character that
we're going to to use to identify the fact that this object is a jQuery object.
To select an object with jQuery, we'll start off with this dollar sign.
Which is a pointer to a jQuery object.
And then, within the parentheses, we'll pass in a string of the element that we
want, where this pound sign represents an ID.
So in this case, if we want the Wikipedia element we simply use
the dollar sign to represent the jQuery object and
then pass in a string starting with this pound sign or hashtag or
whatever you want to call it, representing the ID of wikipedia-links.
Now wiki element represents a jQuery object of the Wikipedia links element
on the page.
We'll be using two different methods for
AJAX requests, the .ajax method and the .getJSON method.
Both methods take in a URL and then some optional parameters.
Check out the links in the instructor notes for
more details on jQuery's different AJAX methods.